thank you well thank you so much for
that introduction and thank you to the
conference organizers for inviting me to
be here I'm really excited to get to
talk to you guys and I also want to say
thank you to this community because as I
will describe in my talk this morning my
team relies on a lot of the tools that
have been implemented and maintained by
this community to do our work so thank
you for the work that you do it makes
our work possible this morning I'm going
to tell you a little bit about my
organization and what we do I'll go over
very briefly the two primary analytical
methods that we rely on and then
basically I'll go through a couple of
quick examples to highlight the ways
that we use some of these tools my idea
this morning is that these are just
examples not tutorials so I will sort of
gloss over some of the implementation
details but of course during QA or
offline afterwards I'm happy to dig into
all of those details and then I'll wrap
things up well as was mentioned I'm the
executive director of the Human Rights
data analysis group or HR dag were a
nonprofit organization based here in San
Francisco and what we do is we provide
the analytical underpinnings for human
rights advocacy work so in a sense were
the scientists behind the scenes for
other human rights advocacy
organizations collectively our team has
been doing this work for a little over
25 years and we've had the great fortune
to work to partner with a wide variety
of organizations everything from large
international organizations like Human
Rights Watch or Amnesty International to
various United Nations missions to truth
Commission's to local grassroots
nongovernmental organizations now where
our analysis ultimately ends up varies
from project to project and country to
country that we work in sometimes we
produce a memo or a white paper or a
technical appendix to a Truth Commission
report but I think one of the most
tangible and
Abell ways that our analyses can
contribute to justice is when were
invited to testify in court cases has
happened in 2002 with my colleague and
HR dad co-founder dr. Patrick ball when
he testified against slobodan milosevic
at the International Criminal Tribunal
for the former Yugoslavia what he's
presenting here are patterns of refugee
flow as people fled across the border
into Albania and also patterns of known
killings that occurred during that
conflict he also testified in 2013 this
time in Guatemala against general efraín
ríos Montt who was the de facto leader
of Guatemala in the 1980s and was
charged with acts of genocide the
analyses that we presented in that case
were a comparison of the relative risk
of death for members of the indigenous
population as compared to the relative
risk of death for members of the
non-indigenous population and the wide
disparity in those taint in those
differences in relative risks the
lawyers argued were consistent with
patterns you would expect to see if acts
of genocide were occurring no Rios Montt
was found guilty but that verdict only
stood for 10 days the Constitutional
Court overturned the verdict on a legal
technicality there are efforts right now
to restart that trial but there is a
long and winding legal road ahead of
those efforts most recently last year
Patrick testified again against his
Shane hob ray the former leader of Chad
in the 1980s this time Patrick presented
crude mortality rates for prisoners in
prisons run by secret police under the
command of his Shane hob ray now this
particular story has a slightly better
coda
just a few months ago in May of this
year his Shane Hari was found guilty and
sentenced to life in prison so those are
some of the biggest most visible
outcomes of some of our work but what's
the actual analytical work that we're
presenting in those cases well we rely
primarily on two classes of methods one
of which is record linkage or database
deduplication
and just to get a sense who is already
familiar with record linkage record
linkage problems okay so this crops up
in a wide variety of applications
essentially it involves needing to
identify when multiple records refer to
the same individual or event or entity
and it'll talk about how that crops up
in our specific work but this is an
incomplete list of the references that
have influenced our thinking and our
work in this particular area and perhaps
most applicable for this audience of
course is that we rely very heavily on
syfy numpy and SK learn to do this
particular piece of our work
the other main analytical method that we
use is a class of statistical tools
called multiple systems estimation or
sometimes where it was developed in
ecology it's referred to as capture
recapture this is a broad class of tools
that's been developed in everything from
ecology to demography to statistics to
public health research and now to human
rights work again this is an incomplete
list of the references that have
influenced our thinking on this work
primarily we implement our MSC work in a
variety of our packages given the title
of this conference I'm gonna focus this
morning primarily on the work we do in
Python but if folks want to talk about
art as well I'm happy to get into that
during QA or offline afterwards so to
get into this morning's particular
example this project started as so many
of our projects do when a partner
approached us with some data and a
question what happened was in 2012 the
United Nations office of the High
Commissioner for Human Rights came to us
and at the time they had access to four
different lists of named victims who had
been killed in the ongoing conflict in
Syria and they came to us and they said
this is a little bit different from the
kinds of situations we usually work in
we don't usually have multiple sources
and we're not really sure how to make
heads or tails of this information and
so we partnered with them between 2012
and 2014 and we published a number
joint reports this is the last official
one from August 2014 but I should
emphasize that this headline is missing
two very important modifiers because
what those reports in fact described was
the number of documented identifiable
victims who'd been killed in Syria and
if you think about the nature of an
ongoing conflict like the one that's
happening in Syria right now it rapidly
becomes clear that documented
identifiable victims must be a subset of
the total number of victims because of
course there are individuals who have
been killed whose names we do not yet
know whose stories have not yet been
told and it's our job as statisticians
as data scientists to use the tools
available to us to estimate what we
don't know but that's actually a whole
nother talk we have to start with what
we do know and with what has been
observed and recorded and so that's the
work that I'm going to talk about this
morning in this particular case we start
with four sources there's an asterisk
there because if you're familiar with
the UN reports the number of sources
vary across the reports and actually the
specific sources that we had access to
varied over the course of that
collaboration but the work that I'm
gonna talk about specifically this
morning is involving information from
four sources the Center for statistics
and research Syria the Damascus Center
for Human Rights studies the Syrian
Network for Human Rights and the
violations documentation center now
between those four sources there are
over 400,000 records but I really need
to emphasize and make absolutely clear
that that in no way implies that that's
the number of victims in this conflict
that's the number of named victims
across all four of those sources and
there's a lot of duplication in those
records because some victims may be
reported to the same source multiple
times
perhaps by different members of their
community or the same victim may be
reported to multiple sources perhaps
each of the sources have access to the
same original information be that a
religious leader or a morgue record or
hospital records so this is the
aggregated total number of named victims
across all four of these sources and
this is why we start with a record
linkage problem because we need to
identify those multiple records that
refer to the same individual and for
this morning the records that I'm
talking about cover the period from the
beginning of the conflict through the
end of last year so when I talk about
sources and records what do I mean what
does the data actually look like in this
case it literally is a list of named
victims this is a screenshot from the
violations documentation Center this is
a public-facing website that they
maintain so anyone has access to this
information that's part of their
advocacy efforts they believe it's
important to make this information
available to draw attention to the
conflict and tell the story of the
victims and all four of the groups
record very similar information the name
of the victim the date and location
where they were killed and then
occasionally we get other demographic
information in most cases we know their
sex rarely do we know their age although
the groups do try and record that
information and a few other bits of
demographic information so like I said
this becomes a record linkage problem
because the first thing we need to do is
to identify the total number of uniquely
identified victims who are described by
these four sources so this diagram
describes the way our team thinks of
this record linkage problem and if
you're familiar with this class of
methods specifically what we implement
is supervised record linkage so the
outside of the circle everything that
talks about human labeling and starts
with a TS
that's where we send records out to
humans and ask them to review it there's
a lot of iteration through those loops
I'm gonna primarily focus this morning
on the middle of the diagram and
specifically I'm gonna focus mostly on
compare classify and cluster but just to
very briefly explain sort of the process
that the data goes through in this
pipeline of course we import the post
processed analysis ready information
from each of our sources and then the
first thing we have to do is a step
called blocking and that's because the
first way that we want to think about
these records if our goal is to identify
multiple records that refer to the same
individual we need to compare pairs of
Records to each other so we need to
start to think of our records like this
and just out of curiosity do I have any
Arabic speakers in the audience it looks
a little funny right because when I mix
Arabic and English one of the languages
has to end up backwards and so the
Arabic names here are backwards so my
apologies but this is how we start to
think about the records but if we start
with 400,000 records and we draw every
possible pairwise comparison it becomes
computationally intractable very fast so
the first thing we need to do is to
figure out a set of rules to reduce the
number of pairwise comparisons we need
to make but it's complicated because any
pair wise comparison we choose not to
make is a potential match that we're
going to miss that we'll never have a
chance to go back and get so we have
these competing interests where we want
to reduce the number of comparisons we
have to make down to something that is
feasible but we also want to make sure
that we're comparing all the records
that we should so we want to make some
rules so that we reduce these records
down to groups of records that are
already similar in some way now it turns
out that this problem is actually so
complicated
and my colleague Patrick Ball wrote a
five-part blog series describing how we
ultimately solved this problem it's
available on our website it's in a
corner of the website we're developing
called the tech corner where we're
starting to include more of these
technical details of some of our work
and it's all written in Jupiter
notebooks and includes code snippets so
you can work through all of those
details if you're curious about them but
that's the blocking step so now I'm
gonna focus primarily on the next three
so if we think that we've finished that
first step we miraculously somehow have
a number of comparisons that's
manageable now we need to numerically
summarize how similar or dissimilar each
of those pairs of Records are so we need
to create some feature vectors that
describe for example the number of days
apart between the recorded dates of
death whether the location of those
deaths is geographically nearby and then
most of the action of course is in the
names so we want to do some typical
things we want to look at edit distance
between the names we use levenshtein and
djaro implementations in python we want
to look at the phonetic similarities of
the names we use a metaphore
implementation in python we want to look
at the name tokens we want to see how
similar in a variety of ways all of
these records are so we end up at the
end of the day with these feature
vectors for each pair that we consider
and that summarizes how similar or
different each pair is to each other and
now we need to make a decision are those
pairs in fact the same individual person
and to do that we need a classification
model now fortunately for us SK learn
has basically any classification model
you might ever want to consider and it
also has baked in all of these really
useful metrics for evaluating those
classification models and I also have to
say that the documentation for SK learn
is so useful for carrying out that
evaluation for making decisions
about how your classification models are
performing and so here we're just trying
out a few different classification
models trying to make some decisions and
what we're feeding into these models are
those feature vectors the numerical
summaries of how similar or dissimilar
each pair are and the labeled data or
the training data that we've generated
by sending pairs of records out to
humans and asking them to label them yes
they refer to the same individual no
they don't refer to the same individual
and in the literature this role is
actually referred to as an Oracle which
i think is possibly the best job title
ever so we have a couple of Oracle's go
out label a subset of the data and then
that's what we're feeding into these
classification models so in this case
we're trying a random forest a decision
tree and logistic regression and wolf
the random forest is killing us but the
what we're feeding that model is the X
are those comparison vectors or feature
vectors and the Y are the labels from
the oracle reviews and then vectors is
just the pandas dataframe that that data
lives in and then what we're going to
get out of each of these models is
technically a score I think of it as a
probability depending upon what model
you're fitting it may or may not truly
be a probability but essentially it is a
way to make a decision about whether
those two records refer to the same
individual or not so you use the metrics
that are baked into a scaler and you
evaluate your different model
possibilities and ultimately you make
some kind of a decision in our case we
actually ended up going with X G boost
but that's how you classify records as
referring to the same individual or not
but now we only have considered pairwise
comparisons and now we need to move to
clustering because if I decide based on
the score that I get out of a
classification model
that record a and record B are the same
person and record B and record C are the
same person is it the right thing to do
to transitively close those
relationships and say records a B and C
are a cluster of three that all describe
the same person well that's where we
need to start and so again this is where
we turn to Network X and then a class of
functions that are inside PI cluster
hierarchy so the first thing that we're
doing here is we're just reading in
those classified pairs and I included
this little code snippet mostly because
I wanted to highlight we've read in over
44 million pairs so we're not quite to
Big Data yet we can pass that around in
memory but it's a big enough file that
we need to be really thoughtful about
any manipulations we're going to do to
it any sort of passing back and forth
that we're going to do and these 44
million classified pairs are what come
out of that first blocking step if we
didn't go through that complication of
blocking we would have billions with a B
pairs so just getting down to something
that we can handle in memory requires
that first step but fortunately for us
we do get down to something that is very
manageable so we read in all of these
pairs that now have scores associated
with them from our classification model
and now we're going to group them into
clusters so we're going to use Network X
to draw a graph we're gonna set a
somewhat arbitrary threshold because
it's something that we're gonna
experiment with moving around on and
we're going to use that threshold to say
any pair that has a score above that
threshold we're going to declare a match
we're gonna say that pair of records
refers to the same individual and we're
going to use those
positive pairs to add edges to our graph
and then from there we can generate
these connected components with this
which essentially are our clusters they
do that transitive closure they say if
these pairs match and these other pairs
match bring them together into a cluster
which is a pretty reasonable place to
start but if you we look at those
connected components and we look at the
size of the clusters they generate
largely they generate fairly reasonable
clusters of small sizes but then we have
a few out there at the tail that are
very big and in fact in this particular
case we have one cluster that contains
over 12,000 records and I don't believe
that's true I don't believe one person
was reported to these sources 12,000
times and that's the weakness of
transitive closure is that sometimes you
have a few records that appear to be
similar to a lot of other records and
you need to go break those back up and
the best way that we've found to do that
is using hierarchical agglomerative
clustering which again thank goodness
baked into SK learn or baked into sci-fi
my apologies but it turns out that it's
very slow to run and that it's very
complicated to get to run over all of
these different connected components and
so again this is one of those
complicated problems that Patrick ended
up writing up for us and our tech corner
and I really enjoy in this particular
write-up he describes how he
enthusiastically said about solving the
wrong problem for a few days I imagine
all of us can sympathize with that and
so he highlights sort of going through
the process of recognizing what the
right problem was which in this
particular case was that there were
multiple different ways to implement the
hierarchical agglomerative clustering
algorithm and he needed two different
ways because one way was faster for
smaller clusters and one way was faster
for bigger clusters and so he needed a
mixed solution
and so this blog post again sort of runs
through all of those technical details
that's another Jupiter notebook code
snippets the usual kinds of things one
other thing that I just want to
highlight again from that class of
functions in scifi clustering hierarchy
is a function called dendrograms and we
found this really useful because as we
were going through this process and as
we were evaluating the results that we
were getting we were noticing that when
we send pairs to the oracles and we ask
them yes or no do these refer to the
same individual they had a tendency to
over match which isn't all that
surprising because if all you had to
look at are two records in isolation and
the records are a little bit different
but kind of similar you might be
inclined to say yes those are probably a
match but if instead you see those two
pairs as part of a broader cluster like
this that all have some similarities and
some differences then it gets easier to
identify oh those those two that looked
similar in fact belong two separate
clusters that describe different
distinct individual victims and so what
we started to do in the iterative
process that we work through where we
fit our classification models and we run
our algorithms and we cluster records
together but then we also send things
back to the Oracle for review we develop
more training data and iterate until we
think we've arrived at the right answer
is that sending our Oracle records that
looked like this and in fact including
the dendrogram visualization really
helped them to identify how many unique
individuals are in fact described by
this cluster of Records and then they
could advise us on where that threshold
for scores should be set where should we
set a cut point to actually break apart
these clusters in a way that makes sense
so we really rely on a variety of the
tools in SK learn and inside PI for a
number of steps in this record linkage
work so that brings us to the end of
clustering that's the bulk of this
record linkage work there's a little bit
of merging and post-processing and then
of course we iterate through this
pipeline a lot but the end of the record
linkage piece of the work gets us to the
number of uniquely identified victims
who've been killed in Syria and our
substantive question is how many people
have been killed in Syria which is not
the same question and in fact I've
slightly missed titled my talk this
morning because there's this whole other
step that we have to take using multiple
systems estimation to build from what we
know and can observe to estimate what we
don't know to actually be able to answer
this question but that's a whole nother
talk so I want to wrap up this morning
with a quote from Patrick then I think
really describes the motivation behind
the work that we do because we have a
tendency to really get down into the
weeds of the technical aspects of the
work and the scientific methods and we
are a team of scientists we find all of
those components of our work very
interesting but the reason we dive so
deeply into those technical details is
because at HR dag we believe we are
morally obligated to do the best work
that's technically possible so that the
victims story is heard and believed to
do otherwise disrespects the victims
suffering so I want to say thank you
again to this community for helping us
to do the best work that's technically
possible thank you
I think we have plenty of time for
questions yes
oh great talk thank you I guess my
question is if I'm the defense attorney
for example and and the prosecution is
presenting this kind of evidence isn't I
mean if I'm defending can't I just poke
holes and sort of the entire methodology
and say that you know the data is
sampled wrong or it's doesn't you know I
mean it seems like when you absorb more
complexity in the analysis you've you've
created little entry points for other
kinds of arguments is that does that
happen or yes that's definitely true you
could certainly try and those are
lessons that we're learning over the
course of testifying in these cases in
2002 unfortunately a version of that
basically happened where it wasn't so
much that holes were poked in our
analyses it was that the lawyers and the
judges felt they couldn't evaluate the
strength of the analyses and so they
just chose to disregard them and so
we've been working on I want to say not
so much I mean we always want to present
the most rigorous analyses that we can
and fortunately with these two methods
we have sort of the full strength of the
scientific community kind of backing up
a lot of the choices that we're making
but what we have been really working on
is how can we present such complex
analyses in a way that the courtroom
gets it and feels that it's useful and I
can only say that in the Rios Montt
trial we felt like we had succeeded
because the judge specifically
referenced our work in her findings and
said that it confirmed and amplified the
witness accounts from individuals but it
definitely is an ongoing battle that
we're working on is how to present this
work more clearly and how to develop
more relationships within the legal
system to to develop sets of rules and
standards for evaluating this kind of
evidence in court cases
is I what jurisdictions do these
typically have I'm and I I know some of
them are under ICC but I said you know a
variety of jurisdictional concerns and
how two different courts consider this
kind of evidence differently should I
say the second one that's completely
unrelated now or should I wait for a
second um I think wait for a second
because that's that's a great question
and it is a variety of jurisdictions so
in the Rios Montt case that was a local
Guatemalan courtroom and so that they
have their own sort of jurisdictional
and evidentiary rules and then right
with the International Criminal Tribunal
for the former Yugoslavia was before the
ICC but it also but it also had its own
sort of special tribunal sets so yes
each of these have their own different
jurisdiction and evidentiary rules that
that we have to work with prosecutors to
sort of figure out and understand
mystical data techniques not many of
them are formalized specifically about
statistical data techniques the ICC is
working on that and we're trying to
advise them a little bit through the
not.we HR dag but we the Technical
Advisory Board are trying to help them
sort of through that process but most of
the other international jurisdictions
that I'm aware of have not formalized
statistical evidence in the Guatemalan
case they did formalized rules about
documents but not necessarily
specifically statistical analysis okay
so unrelated there's a purely technical
I don't know anything about Arabic
orthography but I wonder if limit
ization and Metta phone
are there different libraries or
different you know dictionaries that are
used for various languages and what's
the sort of state of Technology about
linguistic understanding of applying it
to different languages yeah yes and no
there are some different dictionaries
depending on sort of which which of
those approaches you're taking and in
fact in one of in one of the blog posts
we have a link to there's kind of a
warning that metaphor
may or may not work appropriately on
Arabic and we're so we're actually
trying to figure that out but what we
found empirically is that even if even
if the meta phone function is not
necessarily reflecting the true phonetic
sound of the Arabic it seems to be
grouping the records in ways that are
useful so we've sort of treated that
more like an implementation problem and
said well even if substantively it
doesn't make sense it seems to be
solving this problem but that's
definitely an area of ongoing study
great talk
very inspiring the question I have is
about the granularity you mentioned like
Oh our team needs to check this and
tracker with the oracles is it on the
individual basis do you simple that very
large data set I mean how are you
dealing with this problem yeah how did
generate training data is is a big
question and we do - to start to just
seed a project we do just sample and and
give the Oracle sort of a random a not
quite simple random but a fairly random
assortment of records to look at first
and then once we've been able to kind of
bootstrap the process what we send the
Oracle after that oh my computer is
telling me that I've been staring at it
for too long my apologies
then after that what we do is once we
have even a bad classification model is
will send the Oracle what are called
least informative pairs and those are
the ones that have a score right near
where you think the threshold should be
so meaning that the model thinks it's a
coin flip the model isn't sure which way
to go and then those are the pairs that
we send to the Oracle so that we can
keep moving pairs out of that middle
because what we really want is the
classification model to say I know it's
yes or no
they are a mother and son team in Ohio
that have an inexhaustible energy for
spreadsheets they're amazing use of
social media I made it easier to collect
records yes and no because there's a
tremendous selection bias with social
media right because there's who has
access to it and especially in the case
of Syria who is savvy enough to get
around sort of the internet outages in
the censorship that's happening so on
the one hand especially in Syria a
tremendous amount of our information at
least partially does come from social
media so in that way it has improved the
information that we have access to but
the groups that we work with and I think
rightfully so do not consider social
media alone to be sufficient and so they
each have their own process for what I
think of is like a pushin up hole so if
information appears on social media then
they'll go use their local networks to
investigate it using more conventional
sources and if they originally get
information through more conventional
sources they may consider it confirmed
if it appears on social media so it has
increased the the ubiquity and the
availability of data but it has added
complexity to the data processing great
talk this is a technical question
I understand you have record linkages
did you try to use any RDFS or anything
similar to that the resource description
framework that the world wide web uses
not that I know of specifically that
that matched what the web uses we have
considered I mean that would come in at
the feature vector state right is that
am I thinking about that
mm-hmm and that would basically help
consolidate it mm-hmm no I can't say
that we've we've taken that that
particular approach but I'd love to hear
more about it
so a lot of what you presented seems to
be kind of like analysis after the fact
but to what extent have you all been
working with the groups that actually
collect the data to be a little more
proactive like is that something you're
also involved in yeah yes and no you
know we absolutely try and provide some
kind of value add to the groups that are
doing the data collection because we
want them to feel engaged we want it to
feel like a true partnership but on the
other hand I also try to be very very
pragmatic about the fact that my
analysis goals are not necessarily gonna
always match up with their advocacy
goals
so just because having them record
information in a certain way would make
my life easier doesn't necessarily mean
it serves their purposes so I do try and
feed back to them some things that I
think will help them but I try to keep
to myself the things that would just
make my data processing life easier
when what
excellent talk thank you very much um so
you mentioned that sometimes the
information the analysis can't be
consumed just because it's too
complicated and I wonder if that's
something that you guys have addressed
in a parallel path like an advocacy path
with with government if government
institutions could embrace some of the
techniques that you're doing then that
task problem might might be different
yeah that would be amazing
I mean to a certain extent you know we
we certainly do consider all of our
projects to be the long game and so we
do work very hard to develop those
relationships where we are gonna have
advocates for the methods I I don't I
can't think of any specific examples
where I can think of like a government
entity that would be they would have the
capacity to sort of take on these
particular methods I think that would
that would be a great end goal but
definitely like one of the examples that
comes to mind is we've been working in
Colombia for decades at this point and
we've just now kind of turned the corner
on our relationship with the government
where they no longer think our findings
are threatening they think they're
useful and so they sort of understood
them at a depth to to sort of be
advocates of them so so we do try and
leverage those those long-term
relationships
so I'd like if you could join me in a
round of applause for an amazing keynote
from dr. Megan price human rights data
analysis